august diehl et valérie page 2 du fis
facilite les acteurs patients des
bécasses loto ce qui la laisse de place
intérieure de grands lacs à l'image vous
voyez toute l'équipe des fille facile
des comédiens valladeres le filet des
caps d'auto free qui sera présenté
benoît magimel
demain c'est le coup la quinzaine des
réalisateurs loups de ma vie d'avoir
cette soirée prévue dès lundi soir
personne n'aurait parlé à rayons et
d'autres êtres manic l'équipe d'une
fille facile
on espère on espère voir à terme
spanning peut-être sans activité étaient
venus à la fin de la projection à vue à
cannes dont les voleurs selon serait
d'abord de manas qui va encore passer le
pilote importations deuxième elles n'ont
inquiété l'antenne pièce si tout va bien
et tout se passera bien et qui triomphe
actuellement
une apparition alors quelle image on
voit toujours l'équipe de une si facile
de kuro sous les écarts du paraître du
parc dans les chimères privé cotisent
vidard que l'on avait vu dans motsch
love est à genoux les ja
et hop et qui donc est si fascinant
c
[Musique]